what I might do for folks who just don't
have the personal context on me that I
alluded to earlier is I'll I'll tell if
it okay with you a bit of my story which
in some ways led to this
conversation and certainly it sounds
like based on what we were discussing
before recording that that people have
mentioned this to you and it's so it's
been it's been a match made for many
reasons so I want to give folks sort of
a contrast by giving present day and
then the story of what happened to me at
my silent Retreat which was a Vasa
Retreat so if we look at for instance
the last two weeks I have meditated
twice a day 20 minutes a day very
straightforward Transcendental
Meditation and there's lots of wacky
weird stuff if you go deep enough and
weird enough with with TM but if you're
taking it for the off-the-shelf offering
and following the basic guidelines I
find it incredibly therapeutic and I
find also difficult to disambiguate I
haven't had any caffeine whatsoever in
two weeks so the combination of those
two for I suppose a lot of sensible
reasons seems to really help sleep I've
been getting some of the best sleep in
the last 10 years probably in the last
one or two weeks I'm sure the abstinence
from coffee and caffeine no small part
of that and I've seen no Adverse Events
whatsoever and I've done a lot of TM
over the years and other types of
meditation but TM I find to be the
easiest
life raft of sorts however if we flash
back and this sort of alludes to the
maybe like the paracelis the dose makes
the poison I approached my Meditation
Retreat and this was at Spirit Rock
which is a beautiful beautiful facility
beautiful campus really run by excellent
people and ended up being very fortunate
that the author of the book you
mentioned a path with heart that Jack
cornfield was at Spirit Rock he ended up
being the person who who
effectively triaged and helped address
the situation I found myself in
ultimately but I I approached the silent
retreat with the wrong mindset and the
wrong set of expectations I thought to
myself I've done lots of meditation if
you add up all the time that I've
meditated it's quite a bit I've spent
time by myself and I've also done a b c
d and e really not recognizing
that they two different for me at least
and for many people two different
species of experience and since I had
heard that it was the last time Jack
would be leading a retreat I'm not sure
if that ended up being the case or not I
decided that I wanted to get absolutely
as much out of it as possible I'd seen
benefits from fasting before I'd seen
benefits
from uh lower doses of psychedelics
before so I thought to myself this is
probably aggressive but why don't a
combine all three and that ended up
being incredibly problematic but not
immediately i' done the fasting so I
fasted going into this week-long
Retreat and then after a few days of
establishing my Baseline let's call it
three days I started adding increasing
doses daily
of the Blended like homogenized dri COC
mushrooms so people might know these
better as magic mushrooms starting at
about 100 Mig and then slowly working up
to about I want to say it was 600 or so
milligram which is is reasonably high
it's far above what one would consider a
micro do micro do let's just call it 50
to 100
milligrams and simultaneously I'm having
this first experience of being silent
for effectively the entire day maybe
outside of asking a question or two at a
Dharma talk at night this is brand new
and what ended up happening just to jump
to the punchline
is around I was having difficulty with
the meditation to begin with I was very
physically
uncomfortable my mind began to
accelerate in terms of just rumination
the velocity of thought and velocity
sort of implies a direction it was more
like a a pingpong ball bouncing around
or a pinball bouncing around in a
machine at increasing speed sort of
nonlinear exponentially growing speed
and it was very uncomfortable and then I
want to say around day four or five I
had this flooding of memories of
childhood abuse and it wasn't just
snapshots it was like being stuck in a
fully
immersive VR experience that was as
convincing as this reality whenever I
closed my eyes so whenever I closed my
eyes that's what I saw it was a
reexperiencing of this these traumatic
experiences from Age 2 to 4 and if
people go to tim. blog truma they can
listen to a podcast about this and
certain modalities that have helped me
but nonetheless I did not expect this
and I was utterly incapable of stopping
it I could not stop it and this went
talk about not sleeping anytime I closed
my eyes so I couldn't sleep so now what
do you have you have
compounding lack of sleep and
I had never heard of this before I
didn't think this was a possibility I
certainly thought it was a unique
experience unique to me I should be able
to figure this out but eventually got so
desperate I was like I'm not going to be
able to function I mean I I I am able to
navigate my daytoday here right now with
extreme pain but I've I have no
confidence I'll be able to go back to
normal life and make decisions manage my
business interact in all the ways that
are necessary
and that's when I set up meeting with
Jack and thankfully he had the
experience he has a lot of experience
also as a clinical psychologist with
Cutters with people who have been abused
with veterans who have lost limbs and
have moral injuries and PTSD he has a
lot of mileage with many different
patients and clients and meditators so
he was able to thank
God provide a safety net and provide me
with recommendations to clinicians and
so on therapists I could meet to try to
address this but if he had not been
there I shuddered to think what would
have happened so that's the story and
ultimately was able to sort of pull out
of it and manage life but not everyone
has access to Jack and the contrast and
I'll I'll shut up in a second between my
day-to-day over the last two weeks all
upside and that experience
are just black and white I mean there's
there's really no comparison
interestingly and I'll add one more
thing I recently spent a week in
isolation in the wilderness fasting for
that entire week and it was not nearly
as challenging but I did see some
similar symptoms let's say in terms of
that increased speed of the pinball
bouncing around my head as did another
person I was with so two for two without
any attempt to meditate which raises all
sorts of questions right so it's hard
for me to parse what caused what I
experienced but I know that it was
terrible and without Jack I would have
been for lack of a better uh
technical
term how common is that kind of
experience I guess and uh certainly feel
free to start wherever you'd like
or pick that apart in any way that makes
sense uh but it was a disaster
unmitigated disaster and I'm very
fortunate I had someone like Jack
because I had actually spoken with one
other a junior teacher at the time and
she was unequipped she was not equipped
to handle what was happening but Jack
was yeah so many different
thoughts thank you for coming to my TED
Talk I mean one is just wow and and like
wow on so many ways like wow that that
happened to you and two that you're
talking about it
publicly that's amazing so thank you
because I think it's going to be really
helpful to a lot of people my
pleasure